hello everyone, today I’m visiting me,
or rather, visiting our family, a
polyglot slyly
prela who, quite recently, we
decided to bring him to the dacha to feed
dumplings with homemade dumplings and now
I want to ask you how you all this lari
said it’s just great because of
course  i'm in moscow tomorrow
but we're in the dacha it's just unbelievable
because the moon is full of
snow because it's real russia
it's clear that it's certainly a very interesting
place there are a lot of tourists and i think that
everyone should go here to
see how can  standing behind a real
restaurant on the noise say all the same not
russia as always give to the capital it's not the
whole country i think that in principle
for example tourists italy and the details
say i was in russia of course went
to moscow i'll show you to drink and tyndall
russia is a huge country i thought  what to be
here it's just
with you asian how are you pelmeni
russian pelmeni not only us or
pickles with pickled tomatoes  ami
very very good
I am happy and glad tomorrow we
will show our hands to Serpukhov our little fool yes
wonderful handsome but in general
all this we did here started for the sake of the
conference in principle of course I
will tomorrow have a market so that
richard more if he sings yes yes yes with
richard simka there after tomorrow we have
plans to visit the red square yes it is
far and wide on further we have to
see it to knit but sunday we
already have a conference
yes so sunday at 10 am together
with us to talk about the
study is given by and thus
study to study  languages languages because I think that
eople and I think that many people think that
he sticker on
he body is, of course, excellent, but I also thin
that it destroys the message itself, I think that where
t is to speak well, it's not as diff
cult as Yuya think
think something is possible la
er  with the Internet, everything is possible now
that's what I want to say perfectly
excellent perfectly you decide for yourself, but on the second
day it will also be after the end  conference than the
author of the idea yes this is a master class this
means that at the conference I am talking about
learning learning languages learning languages in ge
nd then practice because in
rder to speak well you ne
d practice that practice is the most import
nt thing in the master class I will explain how how to
earn and
languages well my husband and I will come to you were
n the front row excellent that it will
e useful for everyone yes I'm sur
e of it tell me a secret that's all then yes w
'll see you in the next video and w
will definitely see you at the conference happy
everyone bye bye